[Music]
on this tuesday night manitoba and
toronto move
to code red the new restrictions imposed
as kovit 19 spreads
out of control you should assume it is
everywhere
the prime minister's plea to do the
right thing and mounting pressure
from alberta doctors if we don't do
something
we will see death rates
and refrigerator trucks in the front of
our hospitals plus how a circuit breaker
lockdown
would work indigenous groups swallow up
a nova scotia seafood giant
that deals significance and potential
risk
and troubles with the transition what's
really behind donald trump's refusal to
concede the presidency
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we've watched it happen in other
countries like
england france and parts of italy and we
knew canada
was not immune to a second wave of
covid19 now it is happening
the virus is spreading so fast in some
regions new restrictions
are the only thing that can stop it and
today the entire province of manitoba
and canada's largest city moved to code
red
i want to warn you in the plainest
possible terms that covet 19
is out there at levels we have not
seen before you should assume
it is everywhere and that without proper
precautions
and protections you are at risk
of infection
for the next 28 days toronto bars and
restaurants will remain closed to indoor
dining casinos and bingo holes will also
be closed
group fitness classes are banned people
are being urged to not
socialize with anyone outside their
immediate household and to work from
home
whenever possible and starting on
thursday all of manitoba will move to
code red too that means no social
gatherings
non-essential retail stores will be
limited to curbside pickup
restaurants move to takeout and delivery
only gyms rec centers churches and hair
salons will be closed though
schools and daycares will stay open and
non-essential travel is discouraged
we've been pleading with manitobans to
follow the fundamentals but the numbers
continue to climb
it's clear that further action is needed
and this action is
needed now here's why manitoba continues
to have the highest number of active
cases per capita of any province
376 cases per 100 000 people
the second highest is alberta followed
by quebec
then saskatchewan and british columbia
covid fatigue and fears of businesses
going under has led to some pushback
against imposing new restrictions
today prime minister justin trudeau
urged political leaders in canada
to do the right thing as he put it
i would hope that no leader in our
country is easing public health
vigilance because they feel pressure not
to shut down businesses
i understand that worry but let me tell
you
that's how we end up with businesses
going out of business
the prime minister said if provinces
need more federal financial support for
businesses
they should ask for it david aiken has
our top story tonight
we're seeing record spikes this morning
across the country
so i urge the premiers and the mayors
to please do the right thing
act now to protect public health
prime minister justin trudeau would not
name the premiers or mayors that
need to do more but it was pretty clear
where the hot spots of the country were
as the day broke
some parts of ontario alberta and
manitoba
i think the mayors would encourage the
provinces to
follow the the evidence and enact the
measures to protect
uh business for the long term and uh uh
human being and and life in the short
term
resistance to more lockdowns comes from
a concern that the risk to local
economies
outweighs the health risk trudeau says
that's the wrong way to think because
his government is providing subsidies to
ease any pain from lockdowns
we will be there as a federal government
with direct supports
for workers for families for businesses
for business owners
but ontario's premier for one says more
support for
employers is crucial we need more
support for businesses that's what we
need we we need
more support financial support and i'd
be more than happy to sit down and talk
to the prime minister about
that support in quebec's francois lego
says premiers have been telling trudeau
for months
to boost health transfers because we
need to hire people
and to our people we need to know
if we'll have the financing in two years
and three years from now and
so far most of the money announced by
justin trudeau since the beginning
the beginning of march is
non-recurrent money one thing the
premiers and the prime minister do agree
on
now is not the time for ottawa to invoke
any of its emergency powers to
force the province to do something the
prime minister has not used those powers
at any point in this pandemic
and does not want to do so now donna
david aiken in ottawa thank you the
virus is spreading fast through alberta
too where there's been
some reluctance to impose tighter
restrictions in a letter to premier
jason kenney a group of doctors from
across the province warns
of catastrophic consequences to the
health care system
they say hope is not a strategy that
what is needed is a short
sharp circuit breaker of lockdowns
heather urix west reports
after last spring the concept of
shutting all but essential services is
now familiar to canadians
but this time officials say in manitoba
the lockdown
won't last long the short sharp set of
restrictions to stop the spread of coven
19 in manitoba
and to bring the entire province under
the same restrictions
it's known as a circuit breaker the idea
is that when covet 19 is spreading
exponentially through a community
a short period of lockdown can break
chains of transmission
causing growth to slow but it can't stop
virus spread completely because
essential businesses
cannot close certainly an approach like
this is not without
uh possible harms we also have to think
about the potential negative economic
and psychological ramifications of this
we've seen other jurisdictions
implement sweeping lockdowns
indiscriminately violating people's
rights
and destroying livelihoods nobody wants
that to happen
here in alberta but while alberta's
premier continues to reject the idea a
growing number of the province's doctors
are sounding the alarm if we don't do
something
we will see death rates
and refrigerator trucks in the front of
our hospitals
and we have a narrow window to be able
to deal with this and we can
deal with this if we shut things down
for two weeks
more than 70 alberta emergency room and
intensive care physicians sent a letter
to the alberta government monday
asking the province to consider the
circuit breaker approach
alberta's top doctor says the idea has
not been ruled out
when we're looking at all of our options
we know that there is no one
perfect way to manage our kovid 19
experience
we need to look at all options on the
table including something like that
circuit breaker
with stakes so high it's a last resort
kind of measure
question is with daily case counts on
the rise how long
do you wait heather urex west global
news calgary
at the start of the pandemic indigenous
communities across the country had few
cases of covid19
that has changed indigenous services
canada says it's aware of more than 2
000 infections among first nations
people
on reserves since the start of the
pandemic as of monday 771 cases were
still active the prairies have been
hardest hit
alberta has recorded at least 620
infections in indigenous people
there are more than 450 cases in
saskatchewan and over 500
in manitoba the manitoba first nations
kobit 19 pandemic response coordination
team
says active cases in the indigenous
population there is far
higher when you include both on and off
reserve cases
together they account for about 20
percent of all active cases in manitoba
today prime minister trudeau committed
more than 61 million dollars in funding
to help manitoba first nations
battle covet 19. the money is intended
to support the implementation of public
health measures
to build up capacity for surges in cases
and to ensure
food security there has been an
unexpected
and historic turn of events in the
dispute over indigenous fishing rights
in nova scotia
a coalition of migma groups has entered
a billion dollar partnership to buy one
of the country's largest seafood
operations
clearwater seafoods they will own a 50
stake in the company and gain control of
all of clearwater's
fishing licenses in canada it is a big
move
though as ross lord reports it doesn't
resolve some long-standing issues that
have led to anger
and violence the deal is touted as the
single largest
investment in the seafood industry by
any indigenous group in canada
this is strictly a commercial
transaction with a major
north american company you know canadian
company and uh
we just feel so proud in being able to
be uh
an owner a 50 owner clearwater is
canada's largest holder of shellfish
licenses in quotas
specializing in lobster scallops crab
and shrimp in a statement clearwater
chairman colin mcdonald
says the deal represents great value for
shareholders
and leverages the expertise within the
company while advancing reconciliation
in canada
the deal is worth one billion dollars
indigenous leaders say it will not
solve disputes over their so-called
moderate livelihood fisheries but
analysts say it's a significant
development
a pure business deal we're seeing a
growing number of these
there's a community in northern yukon
that actually owns 49
of a of a regularly scheduled airline
there's communities around fort mcmurray
who spend 850 million dollars
buying storage capacity for the oil
sands in a review about clearwater a
financial advice website notes
earnings are forecast to grow by 109
percent per year
but it cautions interest payments are
not well covered by earnings
and that profit margins are lower than
last year
not everyone is convinced the deal is a
slam dunk the chief of the sebagon
aggety first nation
who's been forced to literally fight for
indigenous fishing rights
says he needs more information before
supporting it there's always a
a risk i guess so we need to iron out
that and see if it's a good risk first
return so we'll see very shortly and um
we'll go from there if the sale goes
through leaders hope it creates more
jobs for indigenous harvesters and their
communities
and a company that currently employs
thousands of people we also
certainly have every intention of
integrating the migma
into the company clearwater says its
shareholders will make a final decision
on the deal
in january ross lord global news
windsor nova scotia defiant and
in denial coming up why is president
donald trump refusing to concede and how
is the republican party
responding president donald trump still
claims he won the election
president-elect joe biden calls that an
embarrassment and says nothing will stop
the transition of power when trump's
term
ends in january but as jackson proskow
reports the transition
could be turbulent mr vice president is
it time to concede
despite clearly losing the election
president donald trump's team is working
overtime to discredit the results
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
right we're ready the world is watching
trump's secretary of state suggested
defying the will of voters
have you congratulated vice president
biden yet well republicans insisted
trump is right to challenge joe biden's
victory
until the electoral college
votes anyone
who's running for office can exhaust
concerns about counting
no reason for alarm the trump
administration is still blocking any
attempt at transition
and stopping agencies from cooperating
with biden
i think it
will not help the president's legacy
the rest of the world seems to have
moved on leaders are lining up to engage
with the president-elect
including trump allies like turkish
president erdogan
and british prime minister boris johnson
i look forward very much to working with
president
biden exactly four years ago
outgoing president obama invited
then-president-elect trump to visit the
white house
because if you succeed then the country
succeeds trump's defiance today
is unprecedented so is his relative
silence following the election
instead he's tweeting up a storm about
unfounded claims of election fraud that
he has yet to prove
while launching lawsuits that are not
supported by evidence
jackson there's obviously a real push to
try to keep the trump brand alive
even though he lost there are lots of
theories about why he wants to hang on
and many of them
involve money right
that's right donna in fact the trump
campaign has been bombarding supporters
with emails
soliciting money to help with what they
say is a court fight against the
election
in reality though when you read the fine
print it points out that the majority of
that money
is actually going to be used to retire
trump's campaign debts
donna all right jackson proskow in
washington thank you
is it time to concede still ahead
trump's party hits a loyalty crossroads
you're watching global national
now that the u.s election is over it's
safe to say much of the world is
relieved american politics is so divided
and president trump was such a disrupter
it was hard to know what was going to
happen next
now that he's lost it's the future of
the republican party that's uncertain
will it remain the trump party that's
what eric sorenson is looking at tonight
the colvit-19 crisis is mushrooming
south of the border
the numbers rising in 46 states more
than a hundred thousand cases daily
could soon be two hundred thousand say
experts
president trump said the kovid's story
would disappear the day after the
election
for him perhaps but while he has had
nothing to say about it republican
governors are dealing with hospitals
close to being overwhelmed
they are really at the brink of not
being able to take any more people and
the overflow mode
particularly in our intensive care units
president-elect biden has struck a covet
advisory council
and is calling for leadership from
washington we're a mask but donald trump
is still president
and he is focused not on covet 19 but on
discrediting and overturning the
election results
some republicans at the state level are
speaking out i think the president's
comments that there's some
national conspiracy around this aren't
supported by
any of the facts and they are
damaging to democracy
questioning the election's legitimacy
has angered republican officials in
georgia
since they run the elections there what
i don't like is people out there trying
to undermine the system
but in washington republicans still need
trump they're worried they could lose
control of the senate if two january
runoff races in georgia don't have the
full backing of trump and his supporters
mr vice president is it time to concede
so republicans in d.c have circled the
wagons to protect trump by not
questioning what he's doing
do you suspect fraud anywhere else i
can't speak to that
trump they realize is still more popular
than they are there's no place where
the the majority of the republican party
isn't more loyal to trump than
against trump so he's going to try and
you know still be
the centerpiece of the republican party
perhaps even as the republican party is
trying to move on from
from his four years some in the gop may
quietly be looking ahead to a joe biden
presidency
i know joe biden i shared with him
we got along i'll be fine but if there
are republicans who would welcome the
end of this chaotic presidency
they have something else to keep them up
at night rumblings that donald trump
could run for president again in 2024
eric sorensen global news
next the mission to properly represent a
fallen soldier's
faith
tomorrow we will observe remembrance day
and honor all those who fought and never
came home
thousands are buried in war grave
cemeteries many of the graves marked
with a name and a simple
cross but not all of those who were
killed were christian
and now 75 years after the end of the
second world war
there's an effort to fix some old
mistakes
abigail beeman has the story
he served overseas in 101 squadron based
in england
which was the squadron that had probably
the most losses
morley was fortunate enough to bail out
when the plane was shot down but he
landed in a tree
we don't know exactly what happened
except the locals told investigators
that the germans
shot him they shot him while he hung
there
so it was a very terrible situation
morley ornstein was just 20 killed in
action in the second world war
a cross ended up marking his grave in
germany
even though it's clear that he was of
jewish faith
and 75 years went by and nobody noticed
until i did ellen besner wrote double
threat a book about the 17
000 canadian jews who served in that war
when she noticed the cross
she wanted to make it right i'm a mom
of boys who are that age and morley died
and sacrificed himself so my kids could
go to university my kids could finish
high school and my kids could have a
life
here in freedom in canada it was the
least i could do to fix it
besner reached out to a british
historian who's worked tirelessly
changing more than a hundred incorrect
war grave emblems to stars of david it's
part of the struggle against
anti-semitism
it's part of a struggle against people
who lie
about that jews didn't serve in
proportion to their numbers in the
population when in fact the reverse is
true
besner gathered ornstein's war records
you can see his own handwriting
identifying himself as hebrew
in this house he lived for about two
years then came an incredible boost
from another morley who grew up on the
very same toronto street
i remember meeting morley i sort of got
a big grin on my face somebody
finally has the same name as i do
92 year old morley wolf has vivid
memories of the ornstein family
he wrote a letter to the commonwealth
war graves commission
both my parents spoke yiddish and i
certainly have a clear
recollection of morley's parents
conversing with mine on
occasion in yiddish their efforts worked
the different pieces of the puzzle that
come together to mean that we can be
confident that he
identified as a jew and therefore that
is the most appropriate religious emblem
to be going on to his headstone the
transport process to the cemetery in
germany is being held up by the pandemic
but flying officer morley ornstein's new
stone
is ready we showed it to his old friend
well earned real desert
those involved hope sharing ornstein's
story could help find some relatives the
commission was never able to
all those years ago abigail beeman
global news
global news will have live coverage of
tomorrow's remembrance day ceremony
in ottawa you can watch it at 10 30 a.m
eastern
7 30 a.m pacific we'll also be streaming
it
live on our website globalnews.ca
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the sunrise
over toronto we'd love to see your
canada please
send it to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye